This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. 20 years ago, back in 1996, a crowd of reporters and politicians gathered in the White House Roseville. President Bill Clinton stepped up to the podium and announced that he was signing a landmark bill. It would dramatically redesign welfare, the $16 billion government program that millions of poor Americans relied on for basic support. In this as well as in other press conferences, Clinton made it clear that a central tenant to his redesign was the idea of welfare to work. First and foremost, it should be about moving people from welfare to work. This new reform said that in order to collect welfare, recipients would need to work at a job. To transform a broken system, the traps too many people in a cycle of dependence,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。20年前，也就是1996年，一群记者和政客聚集在白宫玫瑰园。比尔·克林顿总统走上讲坛，宣布他将签署一项具有里程碑意义的法案。该法案将彻底重塑福利制度，这项耗资160亿美元、数百万贫困美国人赖以生存的基本保障计划。在这次以及其他新闻发布会上，克林顿明确表示，他重塑计划的核心原则是“从福利转向工作”的理念。首先，它应该致力于让人们从领取福利转向工作。这项新改革规定，为了领取福利，受助者必须从事一份工作。旨在改变一个让太多人陷入依赖循环的破碎系统，
to one that emphasizes work and independence. To give people on welfare a chance to draw a paycheck, not a welfare check. This whole idea of a paycheck, not a welfare check. This whole idea of a paycheck, not a welfare check, work, not welfare, it's relatively familiar to us now. But there's a complicated backstory behind how it came to be at the center of the reforms that President Clinton passed that day in 1996. Reforms that still affect many people today.
转变为一个强调工作和独立的系统。让领取福利的人有机会获得工资支票，而不是福利支票。这种“工资支票，而非福利支票”的整体理念，这种“工作，而非福利”的整体理念，对我们现在来说相对熟悉。但在这项克林顿总统于1996年那一天签署的改革核心背后，有着一段复杂的背景故事。这些改革至今仍影响着许多人。
Over the last 20 years, the number of families living in deep poverty, unless the $2 a day, is rising. And most of them don't receive welfare. That's Chrissy Clark, the senior correspondent for Marketplace's Wealth and Poverty Desk. She has been researching the history of welfare reform for a podcast series called The Uncertain Hour. And today, we're presenting an adaptation of the first episode from that series.
在过去的20年里，生活在赤贫中（即每天收入不到2美元）的家庭数量一直在增加。而且他们中的大多数人并没有领取福利。那是克里斯蒂·克拉克，Marketplace财富与贫困专栏的资深记者。她一直在为一档名为《不确定时刻》的播客系列节目研究福利改革的历史。今天，我们将呈现该系列第一集的改编版。
It's about a guy who basically pioneered the work not welfare reform, a guy who came to be known as... The Magic Bureaucrat. My name is Lawrence Townsend. Larry, for short, Larry is 79 retired. He's got close-cropped white hair, broad shoulders, and a serious face with one of those army general smiles that never quite turns up at the edges. Today, Larry lives in a beach town in California, where he drives around in a green Cadillac civille that has a brass frame around the license plate. And etched into the brass, it says,
它讲述了一个人，他基本上是“工作而非福利”改革的先驱，一个后来被称为“魔术官僚”的人。我叫劳伦斯·汤森。简称拉里，拉里今年79岁，已经退休。他留着修剪整齐的白发，肩膀宽阔，表情严肃，带着那种军队将军式的微笑，嘴角从不完全上扬。如今，拉里住在加利福尼亚州的一个海滨小镇，他开着一辆绿色的凯迪拉克西维尔，车牌周围有一个黄铜边框。黄铜上刻着：
life works if you work. Larry loves work, just the idea of it. He has a binder full of work ethics slogans that he's collected over the years. These are from famous quotes from all over the world. Alphabetically. Yeah. In fact, there are some that I want to just show you. He starts with A. Aristotle suggested that happiness results from meaningful activity. Who goes all the way down to T. Tolstoy declared it's a duty of each man to earn his living by the sweat of his brow and cow's hands makes independent and virtuous men. Now that was a little
“如果你工作，生活就会有成效。”拉里热爱工作，仅仅是这个想法本身。他有一个活页夹，里面装满了多年来收集的工作道德口号。这些来自世界各地的名言。按字母顺序排列。是的。事实上，有一些我想给你看看。他从A开始。亚里士多德认为幸福源于有意义的活动。一直到T。托尔斯泰宣称，每个人都有义务靠自己的汗水谋生，而勤劳的双手造就了独立和高尚的人。现在，那有点
sexist but the point is very valid. And just as much as Larry Townsend loves the idea of hard work, he hates welfare programs. I've seen so much of damage to people that are on welfare. They have no hope for a better future. They aren't setting a good example for their children. Once when Larry was working in county government, he noticed two children in the welfare office waiting room waiting for their mom and they were pretending to play welfare. One of the children was playing the welfare recipient. The other one was the playing the eligibility worker.
性别歧视，但观点非常有效。正如拉里·汤森热爱努力工作的理念一样，他讨厌福利计划。我看到福利对人们造成的伤害太大了。他们对未来没有希望。他们没有为孩子树立好榜样。有一次，拉里在县政府工作时，注意到福利办公室候诊室里有两个孩子在等他们的妈妈，他们假装在玩“福利游戏”。其中一个孩子扮演福利领取者。另一个扮演资格审查员。
Now you tell me they aren't learning how to get on welfare. Like kids would play house. Playing house in the waiting room while their mother was in the office with the eligibility worker. Now they're catching on about the concept of getting on welfare. Now that one hurt me. And then there's the story about the two women he says he overheard in an elevator once. And this one said to the other one, my oldest child is going to become 18.
现在你告诉我他们不是在学习如何领取福利吗？就像孩子们玩“过家家”一样。当他们的母亲在办公室里与资格审查员交谈时，他们在候诊室里玩“过家家”。现在他们正在领会领取福利的概念。那一次伤害了我。还有他说的有一次在电梯里无意中听到的两个女人的故事。其中一个对另一个说，我最大的孩子快18岁了。
And I won't get welfare benefits, you know. I need to get pregnant. These are the kind of anecdotes that get told and retold among critics of welfare. Individual moments that may not be typical of welfare recipients in general, but for critics, these stories represent all the failings of the system. But in the late 1980s, Larry suddenly found himself in a position to change welfare in a big way, because he became the head of a welfare department in a big suburban county, East of LA, called Riverside. The way he saw it, his role in the welfare office was...
我将无法获得福利救济，你知道的。我需要怀孕。这些是福利批评者中被讲述和重述的轶事。这些个别时刻可能并不代表一般的福利领取者，但对批评者来说，这些故事代表了该系统的所有失败。但在20世纪80年代末，拉里突然发现自己处于一个可以大幅改变福利制度的位置，因为他成为了洛杉矶东部一个大型郊区县——河滨县福利部门的负责人。在他看来，他在福利办公室的角色是……
To invade and conquer. That was my attitude. Quick history lesson here. Since the Great Depression, when the program was first signed into law, welfare had worked pretty simply, at least in theory. If you were a single parent, if your family was poor enough, and if you met a few other technical requirements, you qualified for a welfare check. End of story. There was little expectation that mothers would work.
“入侵并征服”。那是我的态度。这里有一个简短的历史课。自大萧条时期该计划首次签署成为法律以来，福利制度的运作非常简单，至少在理论上是这样。如果你是单亲家长，如果你的家庭足够贫困，并且如果你满足其他一些技术要求，你就有资格获得福利支票。故事结束。当时几乎没有人期望母亲们去工作。
This is James Ricchio, a sociologist who's been studying welfare programs for most of his career. And he's talking about this crazy flip flop that happened over the years around who we thought deserved welfare. When the program began, the whole point was to help single mothers, mostly widows at the time, make ends meet so they could stay out of the workforce,
这是詹姆斯·里奇奥，一位在其职业生涯的大部分时间里一直在研究福利计划的社会学家。他谈到了多年来关于我们认为谁应该获得福利的这种疯狂的反复。当该计划开始时，其全部意义在于帮助单身母亲（当时主要是寡妇）维持生计，这样她们就可以远离劳动力市场，
focus on raising their kids into productive citizens. The attitudes began to change, particularly in the 1970s and early 80s. Part of it had to do with the fact that more middle-class mothers were entering the workforce. So some were asking the question, what about mothers on welfare? Shouldn't they have jobs, too? Joe Hutz is a labor economist at Duke, and he says, well, most welfare moms did have jobs, at least on and off.
专注于将孩子培养成富有成效的公民。这种态度开始改变，特别是在20世纪70年代和80年代初。部分原因在于越来越多的中产阶级母亲进入了劳动力市场。所以有些人开始问，领取福利的母亲们呢？她们不也应该有工作吗？乔·赫茨是杜克大学的劳动经济学家，他说，嗯，大多数领取福利的母亲确实有工作，至少是断断续续地有。
There was this persistent group of largely single mothers, who stayed on welfare for long periods of time, and they didn't work, and arguably had a life of dependence on welfare. And that small, but persistent group of completely dependent welfare recipients started to get all of this focus. There's a lot of academic attention to this, certainly a lot of attention in policy circles to this quote problem of welfare independence. And the view was that, you know, what's key to changing this was to make changes in the welfare system, which encouraged people to work. But then the question was, how? Out in the suburbs of Riverside, California, Larry Townsend had some ideas.
有一群持续存在的主要是单身母亲，她们长期领取福利，不工作，可以说过着依赖福利的生活。而那小部分但持续存在的完全依赖福利的受助者开始受到所有这些关注。学术界对此有很多关注，政策圈内当然也有很多关于这个所谓的“福利独立问题”的关注。当时的观点是，你知道，改变这一点的关键是对福利制度进行改革，鼓励人们工作。但问题是，如何改革？在加利福尼亚州河滨县的郊区，拉里·汤森有一些想法。
And his county got a special waiver from state and federal authorities to try some of those ideas out. I was absolutely stunned that I was given freedom to design a program, to implement a program, to hire the staff that are needed. I felt like it was an honor. It was an opportunity and it had a chance to change the concept of welfare. Larry's changes happened under a California pilot program called Gain, short for greater avenues for independence. So at the time in the 80s, there was the standard welfare approach, which was like, you make less than
他的县从州和联邦当局那里获得了特别豁免权，以尝试其中的一些想法。我非常震惊，我被赋予了设计计划、实施计划、聘请所需员工的自由。我觉得这是一种荣誉。这是一个机会，它有机会改变福利的概念。拉里的改革是在加州一个名为“GAIN”的试点项目下进行的，即“通往独立之路”的缩写。所以当时在80年代，有一种标准的福利方法，那就是，如果你赚的钱少于
X amount, and you get a welfare check every month. And there were two basic avenues counties could take to get more of their welfare families closer to financial independence. One was the education and training route. The idea here was to help poor single moms who'd often dropped out of high school, to get more skills, maybe a GED, to fare better on the job market. But down in Riverside, Larry did not have much patience for that approach. His approach much simpler. Get people into a job immediately.
X金额，你每个月就会收到一张福利支票。县政府可以采取两种基本途径让更多的福利家庭接近经济独立。一种是教育和培训途径。这里的想法是帮助那些经常辍学的高中贫困单身母亲获得更多技能，也许是GED（普通教育发展证书），以便在就业市场上表现更好。但在河滨县，拉里对这种方法没有多少耐心。他的方法简单得多。让人立即找到工作。
Just don't worry about, are you trained enough or do you have enough education, just get that job. We're not going to train you for years. We're not going to send you to school for years. We're going to show you how to find a job. No vocational training or GED, just get in the workforce ASAP. Any way you can. You can still hear the conviction in Larry's voice talking about this program almost 30 years later.
别担心你是否受过足够的培训或者是否有足够的教育，只要找到那份工作就行。我们不会培训你几年。我们不会送你去学校几年。我们要教你如何找工作。没有职业培训或GED，尽快进入劳动力市场。任何你能做到的方式。近30年后，你仍然可以在拉里谈论这个项目时听到他声音中的坚定。
Listen to it. How to find a job. And the point wasn't to find a perfect job or even a well-paying job. But at least your foot is in the door and how well you succeed from there is up to you. With an important catch. If you do not cooperate with us,
听听看。如何找工作。重点不是找到一份完美的工作，甚至不是一份高薪的工作。但至少你迈出了第一步，从那以后你成功与否取决于你自己。有一个重要的前提。如果你不与我们合作，
we will take you off of welfare. Your children will still get money from us, but you won't. To carry out his jobs first plan, Larry restructured his welfare office to run job search classes and job clubs for welfare recipients. James Ricchio and Joe Hutz, the sociologist and the economist we heard from a minute ago, both sat in on some of Riverside's job clubs,
我们将取消你的福利。你的孩子仍然会从我们这里得到钱，但你不会。为了执行他的“工作优先”计划，拉里重组了他的福利办公室，为福利领取者开设求职课程和求职俱乐部。詹姆斯·里奇奥和乔·赫茨，我们刚才听到的社会学家和经济学家，都参加了河滨县的一些求职俱乐部，
and they left an impression. Imagine people sitting in a circle, chairs in a circle, there'd be a job club leader who would talk about what it means to work, how to find a job, how do you approach potential employers, how do you address? Dealing with testy supervisors? Eventually, the people on welfare would be handed a list of job leads and a telephone and told to start calling around and asking for jobs. Here's Joe Hutz again. And there's a whiteboard, right?
他们留下了深刻的印象。想象一下人们围成一圈坐着，椅子围成一圈，会有一位求职俱乐部负责人谈论工作的意义、如何找工作、如何接触潜在雇主、如何着装？如何应对挑剔的主管？最终，领取福利的人会得到一份工作线索清单和一部电话，并被告知开始四处打电话询问工作机会。这是乔·赫茨。还有一块白板，对吧？
So somebody would get us, you know, an interview and it would go up on the board and everybody, you know, would pause at various points and cheer, right? This is like going to, you know, these weight watcher meetings where, you know, I points in cheer, right? This is like going to these Weight Watcher meetings where I lost 15 pounds, right? I got a job offer and that sense of this is exciting. We're doing something that's really important and novel. You could see how to an impact on the recipients who were involved in these job clubs.
所以有人会得到面试机会，它会被写在板上，每个人，你知道，会在不同的点暂停并欢呼，对吧？这就像去参加那些“减肥者”会议，你知道，我减掉了15磅，对吧？我得到了工作机会，那种感觉很令人兴奋。我们正在做一些非常重要和新颖的事情。你可以看到这对参与这些求职俱乐部的受助者产生了影响。
But those job clubs, the cheers and the whiteboards and the Weight Watchers vibe, they were just the beginning of Larry's plans for the welfare recipients of Riverside. Larry says his vision was much bigger. In fact, we'll hope very safe, with a positive attitude, with the beauty and glory of work. And so I became sort of like a preacher for work. This was a campaign to change hearts and minds and get people excited about getting a job, which involved a lot of marketing.
但那些求职俱乐部，那些欢呼声、白板和“减肥者”的氛围，只是拉里为河滨县福利领取者制定的计划的开始。拉里说他的愿景要宏大得多。事实上，我们希望非常安全，带着积极的态度，带着工作的美丽和荣耀。于是我成了某种工作的传教士。这是一场改变人心、让人们对找工作感到兴奋的运动，这涉及大量的营销。
Booklets, posters, billboards. Full of welfare to work slogans. Success stands on your backbone, not your wishbone. Action-term streams into realities. Get into gear, start a career. The messages were printed on bumper stickers to catch the eye of a welfare recipient walking through the welfare office parking lot on buttons that the welfare intake workers would pin to their lapels. A person who aims at nothing has a target he can't
小册子、海报、广告牌。到处都是“从福利到工作”的口号。“成功建立在你的脊梁上，而不是你的愿望上。”“行动将梦想变为现实。”“进入状态，开启职业生涯。”这些信息被印在保险杠贴纸上，以吸引走过福利办公室停车场的福利领取者的注意；印在福利接待员别在翻领上的徽章上。“一个没有目标的人，有一个他无法射中的靶子。”
miss. He's proud of honest labor. Don't wait for your ship to come in, swim out to it. But even if you somehow miss these messages on the bumper stickers and on posters and pins and outside of envelopes. It was especially hard to miss this. I thought music is a very inspirational form of communication. And so Larry made this CD called Work Makes the Difference. He used $2,000 of taxpayer money, no authorization, to record it. I figured I might get fired over it. But he didn't.
他为诚实的劳动感到自豪。“不要等你的船靠岸，游向它。”但即使你以某种方式错过了保险杠贴纸、海报、徽章和信封外面的这些信息。这尤其难以错过。我认为音乐是一种非常有启发性的交流形式。于是拉里制作了这张名为《工作带来不同》的CD。他未经授权使用了2000美元的纳税人钱来录制它。我想我可能会因此被解雇。但他没有。
This is the first track, the title track. Will your children be the next generation? Or will to be the whole music when people called up the welfare offices. It would play during voicemail greetings. I have to say, since I first heard these songs, I cannot get them out of my head. There are 10 songs in all, different genres,
这是第一首曲目，主打歌。你的孩子会是下一代吗？还是会……当人们打电话给福利办公室时，会播放整首音乐。它会在语音信箱问候语中播放。我必须说，自从我第一次听到这些歌，我就无法把它们从脑海中赶走。总共有10首歌，不同的流派，
to appeal to different demographics, Larry says. There's a song that features a whole rap section. So boarding yourself is helping yourself. You've got to have something that's de-enright. And then there's a song with a kind of slow reggae jam. And then there's a song with a kind of slow reggae jam. And then there's a jazzy Andrews sister's 40 style thing that's very hard not to snap your fingers to But we're not done yet. There are also three different versions of a song called Feel So Good to Have a Job.
拉里说，为了吸引不同的人群。有一首歌包含了一整段说唱。所以，支持自己就是帮助自己。你必须有某种……然后是一首带有慢节奏雷鬼音乐的歌。然后是一首带有慢节奏雷鬼音乐的歌。然后是一首爵士风格的安德鲁斯姐妹40年代风格的歌，很难不跟着打响指。但我们还没完。还有三首不同版本的名为《有工作感觉真好》的歌。
Feel So Good to Have a Job. Feel So Good to Have a Job. Feel So Good, Feel So Good, Feel So Good to Have a Job. And for the Spanish speaking audience. And all these songs were written, composed, produced, and recorded by the staff of the Department of Public Social Services, or SPSS, which was the welfare department that Larry Townsend ran. What happened was he sent out a memo. A paper memo.
《有工作感觉真好》。《有工作感觉真好》。感觉真好，感觉真好，有工作感觉真好。还有为讲西班牙语的观众准备的。所有这些歌曲都是由公共社会服务部（DPSS）的员工编写、作曲、制作和录制的，这就是拉里·汤森管理的福利部门。发生的事情是他发了一份备忘录。纸质备忘录。
Yeah, paper memo. It was an all-staff memo. Keith Rogers was working in the mail room of DPSS back then. His job was to send out the welfare checks that, according to one of the songs he would later write, welfare recipients should be envisioning in their past. The memo from Larry said he was looking for volunteers to take some of the work ethics slogans he'd collected and put them to music, turn them into songs. Keith was a musician. The mailroom thing was just his day job.
是的，纸质备忘录。这是一份全员备忘录。基思·罗杰斯当时在DPSS的收发室工作。他的工作是寄出福利支票，根据他后来写的一首歌，福利领取者应该在过去设想这些支票。拉里的备忘录说，他正在寻找志愿者，将他收集的一些工作道德口号配上音乐，变成歌曲。基思是一位音乐家。收发室的工作只是他的日常工作。
So when he saw this all-step memo, he was like, oh, I got a chance to do my thing. Let me just go up and whip something up and then submit it to Larry Townsend. So after work Keith sketched out a melody, he still remembers it. Well, first temporary and not a way of life. And he sent a demo over to Larry. He loved it. Next day I know I'm up in his office. He says, now you're not doing mail right now, you're going to be a producer, you're going to produce my CD. And I'm like, wow.
所以当他看到这份全员备忘录时，他想，哦，我有机会做我的事了。让我去写点东西，然后提交给拉里·汤森。下班后，基思勾勒出一段旋律，他至今仍记得。嗯，首先是暂时的，而不是一种生活方式。他把小样发给了拉里。他很喜欢。第二天我就在他的办公室里。他说，现在你不用做邮件了，你要成为一名制作人，你要制作我的CD。我说，哇。
Six months in the studio later, with $2,000 of taxpayer money and musical contributions from the mail room on up through county social workers, and they had their CD. It's worth pointing out that before he'd worked in the mail room, Keith had actually been on government assistance himself back when he was struggling to make it as a musician and in between gigs. Yeah, I mean, I received full stamps, you know, but that was just something that I needed until I became gainfully important. That was not anything that I wanted to depend upon.
六个月的录音室工作后，用了2000美元的纳税人的钱，加上从收发室到县社会工作者的音乐贡献，他们有了自己的CD。值得指出的是，在收发室工作之前，基思在努力成为一名音乐家期间，在演出间隙，他自己实际上也接受过政府援助。是的，我的意思是，我领过食品券，你知道，但那只是我在获得有报酬的工作之前所需要的东西。那不是我想依赖的东西。
It was temporary not a way of life. Oh, I knew it wasn't a way of life. Oh, I knew it wasn't way of life. Try to live off flu stamps. Keith was already on board with the message that getting a job was important and he was game to spread the word. You know, you're hearing that
它是暂时的，不是一种生活方式。哦，我知道它不是一种生活方式。哦，我知道它不是一种生活方式。试着靠食品券生活。基思已经认同了“找工作很重要”这一信息，他愿意传播这个消息。你知道，你听到那个
hearing and being pumped all over in the system here and then you might call at some of the welfare offices and, you know, they put you on hold. Yeah, well, fair is a temporary way of life. And I'm thinking, you know, put you on a whole year. Well fair is a temporary way of life. And I'm thinking you know you play certain things over and over again. It does have a subliminal effect.
听到并被系统到处灌输，然后你可能会给一些福利办公室打电话，你知道，他们让你等待。是的，好吧，福利是一种暂时的生活方式。我在想，你知道，让你等待一年。福利是一种暂时的生活方式。我在想，你知道，你一遍又一遍地播放某些东西。它确实有潜意识的影响。
It's like, hey guess what? I want to find his job. And whether it was the songs themselves or the buttons, the billboards, the bumper stickers, the job clubs, or the jobs first strategy all together. Somehow Larry's plan in Riverside seemed to work. The results in Riverside were the most impressive we had ever seen in a welfare to work program up to that time. This is sociologist James Ricchio again.
就像，嘿，猜猜怎么着？我想找份工作。无论是歌曲本身，还是徽章、广告牌、保险杠贴纸、求职俱乐部，还是整个“工作优先”战略。不知何故，拉里在河滨县的计划似乎奏效了。河滨县的结果是我们当时在“从福利到工作”项目中见过的最令人印象深刻的。这是社会学家詹姆斯·里奇奥。
He was actually hired by the government to study Riverside's Jobs First Program. His team followed the families who participated, tracked what happened to them for five years, and compared that to what happened to families who stayed on the plain old welfare program, where they just got checks, no job clubs, or job pep talks. Turns out the ones who participated in the jobs first program, five years later, they were doing way better. On average, had earnings that were 42% higher than those who were assigned to the control group. They were making 42% more money than the families who hadn't gotten any of the jobs first stuff.
他实际上是被政府聘请来研究河滨县的“工作优先”计划的。他的团队跟踪了参与的家庭，追踪了他们五年的情况，并将其与那些留在普通福利计划中的家庭进行了比较，在那里他们只是领取支票，没有求职俱乐部，也没有工作动员演讲。事实证明，那些参加“工作优先”计划的人，五年后，他们的表现要好得多。平均而言，收入比那些被分配到对照组的人高出42%。他们赚的钱比那些没有得到任何“工作优先”支持的家庭多42%。
James also compared the people who went through the jobs first program in Riverside to people who lived in other parts of the state that emphasized education first. And the Riverside jobs first group came out on top in that comparison too. Five years later, they were employed more and had higher wages than the education first group. And because of all of this? Larry Townsend, the director, became a kind of star in this narrow world of welfare reform. But this narrow world of welfare reform was about to widen and play a very big role on the national stage.
詹姆斯还将河滨县参加“工作优先”计划的人与居住在该州其他强调“教育优先”地区的人进行了比较。河滨县的“工作优先”小组在比较中也名列前茅。五年后，他们的就业率更高，工资也比“教育优先”小组更高。正因为如此，导演拉里·汤森在这个狭窄的福利改革世界里成了一位明星。但这个狭窄的福利改革世界即将扩大，并在国家舞台上发挥非常重要的作用。
And Larry's get a job, any job approach for welfare recipients became known as... Riverside Miracle, the Riverside Miracle. The Riverside Department of Social Services received an award from the Harvard Kennedy School of Government, and the Riverside Miracle got a lot of attention on the national news. And I'll just read a few quotes here. From the New York Times, no program has done as much to raise the earnings of people on welfare as one here in Riverside County. And from the LA Times, Riverside is pursuing a notion so obvious as to be stupifying.
拉里对福利领取者采取的“找份工作，任何工作”的方法被称为……“河滨奇迹”。河滨县社会服务部获得了哈佛肯尼迪政府学院颁发的奖项，“河滨奇迹”在全国新闻中受到了广泛关注。我只读几句引语。《纽约时报》称，没有哪个项目像河滨县的这个项目那样，在提高福利领取者收入方面做得这么多。《洛杉矶时报》称，河滨县正在追求一个显而易见到令人震惊的概念。
If you want to get people off welfare, stay on their backs until they get a job. They call me the Magic bureaucrat or something,. It was an editorial, a whole page. But I figured I'd just believe it was the lower the top. Larry has a framed copy of the editorial, hanging in his house. But in all the news coverage, Larry's thoughts about the welfare system sometimes revealed a more aggressive tone than the one
如果你想让人们摆脱福利，就盯着他们，直到他们找到工作。他们叫我“魔术官僚”之类的。那是一篇社论，整整一页。但我认为我只是相信它是……拉里家里挂着那篇社论的装裱副本。但在所有的新闻报道中，拉里对福利制度的想法有时表现出比你在那些歌曲中听到的更具侵略性的基调。
you hear in those songs. In one article from 1993, he says that every time he sees a bag lady on the street, he wonders if it's a mother on welfare who quote, hit the menopause wall, who can no longer reproduce and get money to support herself. I asked him about this quote. Please don't go there. Well, it is out in the public record. I just wanted to give you an opportunity to. And out in the record, eons ago, no, I don't know about
在1993年的一篇文章中，他说每次他在街上看到一个流浪老妇人，他都会想那是否是一个领取福利的母亲，她“撞上了更年期之墙”，无法再生育并获得钱来养活自己。我问他关于这句话的事。“请不要去那里。”“好吧，它在公共记录中。”“我只是想给你一个机会……”“在记录中，很久以前，不，我不知道……”
the deed to clarify it further. Well, since we're going into history, you know, we, the part, part, this whole story is about the history of the... I'd say you've done your job in that regard. So Larry clearly did not want to talk about this, but I still wanted to know whether he ever worried some of his welfare to work rhetoric might be hurtful to people. There is this tricky territory, it seems like in discussions around this
“……澄清它。”“好吧，既然我们要进入历史，你知道，我们，部分，整个故事是关于……的历史。”“我想你在这方面已经完成了你的工作。”所以拉里显然不想谈论这个，但我仍然想知道他是否担心他的一些“从福利到工作”的言论可能会伤害到人们。这似乎是一个棘手的领域，
where there can be stereotypes that come up or feelings of judgment. The example that that talks about, it was a concept where I was concerned about ladies getting into an unfortunate situation and nobody ever helped them to discover how good they are. And that's all he wanted to say. Regardless of what you think about Larry's opinion of work
可能会出现刻板印象或评判感。他谈到的例子，是一个我担心女士们陷入不幸境地，而没有人帮助她们发现自己有多优秀的概念。这就是他想说的全部。无论你如何看待拉里对工作和职业道德的看法，以及它如何适用于谁在领取福利以及为什么，事实是这些观点在20年前被广泛接受。最终，拉里的故事，他的“河滨奇迹”，开始在政治舞台上引起注意。河滨县的结果影响了共和党人和民主党人的想法。然后他将进入议程，这是一系列持续节目中的一个。在福利改革之前的几年里，拉里五次飞往华盛顿特区，在国会作证，讨论如何重组这个耗资约160亿美元的计划。
and work ethics and how that applies to who's on welfare and why, the fact is these opinions were widely embraced 20 years ago. Eventually Larry's story, his Riverside miracle, started getting noticed in political arenas. The results in Riverside influenced thinking among Republicans and Democrats. And then he will come to order, This is one of a continuing series. And in the years leading up to welfare reform, Larry flew to Washington DC five different times to testify before Congress, as they debated how to restructure this some $16 billion program.
（无音频）
If we have heard anything from the witnesses to date, it is work, work, work. That that will work better than anything else we might consider to attempt to cure the, what we would regard as the failure of a welfare in the United States. That's Republican Senator Bob Packwood from Oregon in 1995, just a year before welfare reform legislation would be signed into law. In Packwood's eyes, the Riversideide miracle would be the key to fixing welfare. Mr. Lawrence Townsend, who's the director of the Department of Public Social Services in Riverside, one of the outstanding success examples in the country, Mr. Townsend. And there Larry was in a dark suit with a big blue button pinned to his lapel
“如果我们从证人那里听到了什么，那就是工作，工作，工作。这比我们可能考虑尝试治愈我们所认为的美国福利失败的任何其他事情都更有效。”这是共和党参议员鲍勃·帕克伍德在1995年说的，就在福利改革立法签署成为法律的前一年。在帕克伍德眼中，“河滨奇迹”将是修复福利的关键。“劳伦斯·汤森先生，他是河滨县社会服务部的主任，是全国杰出的成功典范之一，汤森先生。”拉里穿着深色西装，翻领上别着一个蓝色大徽章，
that read, Self-Sufficiency is supporting yourself. Thank you honorable chairman. Backward. Larry told the senators all about his welfare to work program and Riverside all the ways he had enlisted his staff to promote it. If you call Riverside County and nobody answers the phone, they'll get a work ethic message. We have posters in the waiting room. We have produced a compact disc with work ethic music. Identify very much work ethic music. Now we've gone commercial and we've produced a compact disc and we started a new singing group called the Ethics. You sing high-hole high-hole, it's off to work we go or what? You sing high-hole high-hole, it's off to work, we go, or what?
上面写着：“自给自足就是支持自己。”“谢谢尊敬的主席。”帕克伍德。拉里向参议员们讲述了他河滨县的“从福利到工作”计划，以及他动员员工推广它的所有方式。“如果你给河滨县打电话，没人接电话，他们会听到一条职业道德信息。我们在候诊室有海报。我们制作了一张带有职业道德音乐的CD。非常认同职业道德音乐。现在我们已经商业化了，我们制作了一张CD，我们成立了一个新的歌唱团体，叫‘道德’。你唱‘嘿吼，嘿吼，去工作吧’，还是什么？”
But eventually the laughter would die down, and the senators would come to take Larry's methods and philosophy just as seriously as he did. Larry's dismissal of educating welfare recipients as a waste of money and time, his emphasis on getting a job, any job? Both of those ideas show up in various ways in the welfare reform bill that Congress passed and President Clinton signed in 1996. It had a name that Larry would approve of. The Personal Responsibility and Work Opportunity Reconciliation Act. But just a few years after this change was made,
但最终笑声会平息，参议员们会像拉里一样认真对待他的方法和哲学。拉里认为教育福利领取者是浪费金钱和时间，他强调找工作，任何工作？这两个想法都在国会通过、克林顿总统于1996年签署的福利改革法案中以各种方式体现出来。它有一个拉里会赞同的名字：《个人责任与工作机会协调法》。但在这一变化发生仅仅几年后，
it came to light that the thing that all of this reform was based on, the Riverside miracle. It turned out it wasn't a miracle after all. The just get a job approach wasn't the magic fix that everyone wanted it to be. Unfortunately, it wasn't that simple. In the early 2000s, Joe Hutz, the Duke economist, he and two other researchers checked back in on what had happened
事实证明，所有这些改革所基于的东西——“河滨奇迹”，根本不是什么奇迹。“只管找份工作”的方法并不是每个人都希望的那种神奇的解决方案。不幸的是，事情没那么简单。21世纪初，杜克大学经济学家乔·赫茨和另外两名研究人员回访了那些参加过河滨县“工作优先”计划的福利领取者，
to the welfare recipients who'd gone through the Riverside job first program, and they compared their circumstances to folks who'd gone through other programs in counties like LA and Alameda that had focused on education and training. What we found was that, yes, indeed, work first, work better in the first few years out of the treatment. But by years seven and eight and nine. Actually, the effect reversed. Meaning the people who'd gotten more education, more skills training, rather than being
并将他们的情况与在洛杉矶和阿拉米达等县参加过其他侧重于教育和培训计划的人进行了比较。我们发现，是的，确实，“工作优先”在治疗后的最初几年效果更好。但到了第七、第八和第九年。实际上，效果逆转了。这意味着那些接受了更多教育、更多技能培训的人，而不是被
told with buttons and songs and slogans to just get a job, any job, they were doing better. They were more likely to be still in work. They were making slightly more money. And less likely to return to welfare. The effects of the Riverside miracle had all but disappeared. Joe says the Riverside miracle had less to do with Larry's work first tactics and more to do with the fact that in Riverside back then, there was a booming job market for low skilled workers. This plan doesn't work in places where there aren't a lot of low skilled jobs.
用徽章、歌曲和口号告知“只管找份工作，任何工作”的人，他们的表现更好。他们更有可能继续工作。他们赚的钱稍微多一点。而且重返福利的可能性更小。“河滨奇迹”的效果几乎消失了。乔说，“河滨奇迹”与拉里的“工作优先”策略关系不大，更多地与当时河滨县有一个为低技能工人提供的繁荣就业市场有关。这个计划在没有大量低技能工作的地方行不通。
When there aren't jobs out there, you can have all the job clubs you want, right? You can have them calling as many employers as you want. It's not going to change the fact that there aren't no jobs. And by the late 90s, there was very, very little of this kind of labor. Even in Riverside, it turns out a better name for the Riverside Miracle might have been. It's not as catchy, but maybe it's something like the Riverside short-term spike in the labor market that was a fluke and Loud more jobs for a while Something like that. Yeah, that that's probably not gonna get a sound bite the Riverside miracle did not look like a miracle nine years later
当外面没有工作时，你可以拥有所有你想要的求职俱乐部，对吧？你可以让他们给尽可能多的雇主打电话。这不会改变没有工作的事实。到了90年代末，这种劳动力非常非常少。即使在河滨县，事实证明，“河滨奇迹”的一个更好的名字可能是……它不太吸引人，但也许是像“河滨劳动力市场短期激增，那是一个侥幸，暂时提供了更多工作”之类的东西。是的，那可能不会成为新闻片段。“河滨奇迹”九年后看起来并不像一个奇迹。
It didn't put people on a trajectory that was going to last a lifetime. But this discovery that maybe climbing out of poverty in an unpredictable economy takes more than job clubs and songs, that did not get the same kind of media play as the Riverside miracle had gotten. Because in the meantime, the ship had already left the dock. The Riverside miracle had inspired a whole raft of federal welfare reform legislation based on the get a job, any job, work first mantra, and collectively changed how we think about welfare. Today we are ending welfare as we know it.
它没有让人走上一条持续一生的轨道。但这一发现——即在不可预测的经济中摆脱贫困可能需要的不仅仅是求职俱乐部和歌曲——并没有像“河滨奇迹”那样获得同样的媒体报道。因为与此同时，船已经离开了码头。河滨奇迹激发了一整套基于“找份工作，任何工作，工作优先”口号的联邦福利改革立法，并共同改变了我们对福利的看法。“今天，我们正在终结我们所知的福利制度。”
And the thought of revisiting and restructuring welfare, again, just wasn't something that the federal government or the states that ran welfare to work programs had the political will to deal with anymore. Because their view was, oh, we took care of this back in 1994 and 1995, and we don't need to revisit it. It wouldn't be till later that the weaknesses of the get a job, any job, welfare to work approach revealed themselves on a big, painful scale. In the great recession that started in 2008, when job markets crashed all over the country,
而再次审视和重组福利的想法，联邦政府或运行“从福利到工作”计划的州已经没有政治意愿去处理了。因为他们的观点是，哦，我们在1994年和1995年就处理好了，我们不需要再审视它。直到后来，“从福利到工作”的“找份工作，任何工作”方法的弱点才在大规模、痛苦的范围内显现出来。在2008年开始的大衰退中，当全国各地的就业市场崩溃时，
especially for low wage workers. Joe says the Riverside miracle had been such a tantalizing, low-cost, quick fix to poverty, get people off welfare and into self-sufficiency, just inspire them, tell them to get jobs. It was a hard approach to let go of. Unfortunately, after a while we realized these problems are age-old. It's, um, if it were that simple, we would have solved it much earlier. Unfortunately, it wasn't that simple.
特别是对于低薪工人。乔说，“河滨奇迹”曾是一个如此诱人、低成本、快速解决贫困的方法——让人们摆脱福利并实现自给自足，只要激励他们，告诉他们去找工作。这是一种很难放弃的方法。不幸的是，过了一段时间我们意识到这些问题是老生常谈。如果那么简单，我们早就解决了。不幸的是，事情没那么简单。
And the people who went through the Riverside miracle are still dealing with the better suite aftermath. Okay, so we have to, and coral. After going through the Riverside Jobs Program more than 20 years ago, Sophia Ellsman has been off welfare ever since. For the last decade, she's worked in this plus size dress shop. She's the store manager in charge of a small staff and figuring out where to put the pink sweaters so they don't clash with the coral ones.
而那些经历过“河滨奇迹”的人仍在处理苦乐参半的后果。好的，所以我们必须……在20多年前参加了河滨县的工作计划后，索菲亚·埃尔斯曼此后一直没有领取福利。在过去的十年里，她在一家大码女装店工作。她是店经理，负责管理一小群员工，并决定把粉色毛衣放在哪里，这样它们就不会与珊瑚色的毛衣冲突。
But this coral here with this set looks good. The fact that Sophia has a job is evidence that the Riverside Jobs First Program did have its successes. In fact, she was featured in a newspaper article in the early 90s as an example of the Riverside miracle. But for a woman in her 50s, she has a physically taxing job. She's on her feet all day dragging racks of clothes
“但这件珊瑚色的衣服和这套搭配起来看起来不错。”索菲亚有一份工作的事实证明了河滨县“工作优先”计划确实有其成功之处。事实上，她在90年代初的一篇报纸文章中被作为“河滨奇迹”的例子进行了报道。但对于一位50多岁的女性来说，她有一份体力消耗很大的工作。她整天站着，拖着衣服架子
from here to there. My hands are screwed up now. I beg your pardon. And for all this, she makes less than $15 an hour. Sophia lived up to the Riverside program's name. Gain. She found greater avenues for independence. But I asked her, do you consider yourself a gain success story?
从这里到那里。“我的手现在废了。”“请原谅？”尽管如此，她的时薪不到15美元。索菲亚不负河滨县计划的名字：GAIN（通往独立之路）。她找到了通往独立的更大途径。但我问她，你认为自己是一个GAIN成功案例吗？
She thought for a long time. Yes, and no, she said, and then she corrected herself. You know what, to tell you the truth, you know, I've been working for, like, since I was 14 years old. The work requirements, the job clubs, they were actually a bit of a distraction, she says. She'd already had low wage jobs and she knew how to get them. I felt like it was more hindrance to me. Like, gain was a hindrance? Yes, because I had to go there. But I did what I had to do because they said I had to do it, so I did it.
她想了很久。“是，也不是，”她说，然后她纠正了自己。“你知道吗，说实话，你知道，我从14岁起就开始工作了。”工作要求、求职俱乐部，实际上有点分散注意力，她说。她以前做过低薪工作，她知道如何找到它们。“我觉得这对我来说更多是一种阻碍。”“GAIN是一种阻碍？”“是的，因为我必须去那里。但我做了我必须做的事，因为他们说我必须做，所以我做了。”
Sophia has moved out of poverty and off of government assistance, but she says she would have done that anyway. Wellfare was just a temporary bit of help she needed when she and her husband split up. But two decades later, she hasn't moved that far out of poverty. Things are still tight. And rather than getting pep talks to find a job, any job, she wishes she'd had encouragement to get the training to do what she really wanted. I want to be a job, any job. She wishes she'd had encouragement to get the training to do what she really wanted. I want to be a nurse.
索菲亚已经摆脱了贫困和政府援助，但她说她无论如何都会那样做。福利只是她在和丈夫分手时需要的临时帮助。但二十年后，她并没有摆脱贫困太远。生活依然拮据。与其得到找工作、任何工作的动员演讲，她希望自己能得到鼓励去接受培训，去做她真正想做的事。“我想成为一名护士。”
Probably if I got offered, the opportunity to go back to school, right now I could be in a hospital, being an RN. Making a lot more than $15 an hour. A longer version of this story was originally heard on the Uncertain Hour, a new podcast from Marketplace's Wealth and Poverty Desk. It's really good, you should check it out. The Uncertain Hour is Chrissy Clark, Caitlin Ash, Gina Delvack, and Nancy Fargali.
“如果我当时有机会回到学校，现在我可能就在医院里，成为一名注册护士。赚的钱比每小时15美元多得多。”这个故事的较长版本最初是在《不确定时刻》上听到的，这是Marketplace财富与贫困专栏的一档新播客。它真的很好，你应该去看看。《不确定时刻》的成员有克里斯蒂·克拉克、凯特琳·阿什、吉娜·德尔瓦克和南希·法加利。
Ben Tulliday is the engineer, and Mark Miller is the managing editor. editor. 99% Invisible is Shereef Usef, Avery Trufflement, Delaney Hall, Katie Minglecourt, Colestead, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. If you're anything like the people work in our office, you still have the welfare to work jingles stuck in your head. Well, luckily, I have the cure. Last week, one of my favorite artists, P.O.S., of the unstoppable Doom Tree Collective dropped a new track, and he named Chex Me, Roman Mars, at about the two-minute mark. It's the coolest thing that's ever happened
本·图利迪是工程师，马克·米勒是执行编辑。《99%隐形》的成员有谢里夫·尤塞夫、艾弗里·特鲁夫尔门特、德莱尼·霍尔、凯蒂·明格尔考特、科尔斯特德、萨姆·格林斯潘和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7K ALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作。如果你像我们办公室工作的人一样，你的脑海里仍然挥之不去那些“从福利到工作”的叮当声。好吧，幸运的是，我有解药。上周，我最喜欢的艺术家之一，不可阻挡的Doom Tree Collective的P.O.S.发布了一首新曲目，他在大约两分钟的时候提到了我，罗曼·马尔斯。这是发生在我身上最酷的事情，
to me, so I'm gonna play it for you. I'm leaving the song unbleaped. So this is your warning you cool babies This is Wayne and Bear by Minneapolis's own POS I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man
所以我打算为你播放它。我没有删减这首歌。所以这是给你们的警告，酷宝宝们。这是明尼阿波利斯自己的POS带来的《Wayne and Bear》。我不是男人，我不是男人……（重复）
I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man I'm not a man, I'm not a man demeanor of a bomb pop, chilling in a pool with a bomb pop Tripping on a sport finger, jewels on give a fuck Beats about the shit that's bugging you, and watch the news Then realize not to the fear rising by who exactly do I gotta kill Just shouts y'all, I pass if it's my anarchist
（歌词内容）
National distraction, so I break my will, got me strolling in the infinite Here we're getting into it, hatched tag, black lives Some of y'all indifferent Some of y'all don't give a shit Some of y'all don't fuck with it Some of y'all got racism Was all because the president was black Smack dab in the middle of the smack and dab in the zones
In the lab trying to change the y'all pience Our ambiance keep the ambulance Andy peep the battle stands to champ Your boy ain't candy put up You got some and skiddle up my tiger mitt In the spot wearing a bear, I am revenue Punch it in your Googler, check Mary and Webster I'ma hit the road, tryna hang with tiny professor and hard r
在实验室里试图改变你们的氛围，我们的氛围引来了救护车，安迪看着战斗的姿态去争夺冠军，你的男孩可不是软柿子，振作起来，你拿了一些，快溜走吧，我的老虎手套，在现场穿着熊装，我就是收入，在谷歌上搜一下，查查韦氏词典，我要上路了，试着和微型教授以及硬R混在一起
And full cards on these lame nards, tryna catch a Garfield Easily great charm, looking like a fist bite Smile like a break life, eyes all frown, believe words not fit right Tripped to me and slipped to me, I'm tryna spit the plan hammer in the right Hell of snacks in the other hand Trouble in the double sack, medicine the train Stubbles in the way back, running from the lynch man Handled at counter-axe fields, 2020 future
还有这些无聊家伙的满手牌，试着抓住加菲猫，轻易地展现魅力，看起来像是一口咬下，笑容像破碎的生活，双眼紧锁，相信词语并不合适，对我绊倒并滑向我，我试着吐出计划，锤子在右手，另一只手拿着一堆零食，双袋里的麻烦，药物是火车，后方有残茬，从私刑者手中逃跑，在反斧头领域处理，2020年的未来
Yeah, yeah, scalpel, suture, new guns locked in Potter and the abdomen, thanks for the spot Holy living up the map again, catch-gratch feverish Seven-year itchy with a bag full of bullfeting on ditty Couple dollars in a full tank shifty Manou Samaroli and Roman Marsas whipin' yeah Whip-whipin' but bendin' the corners up Ah! Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Fifth gear and flip, fist in the...
是的，是的，手术刀，缝合，新枪锁在波特和腹部，谢谢这个位置，再次点亮地图，抓住发烧，七年之痒，带着一袋吹牛的迪迪，油箱里有几块钱，马努·萨马罗利和罗曼·马萨斯在驾驶，是的，驾驶着但转弯了，啊！是的，是的，是的，是的，五档翻转，拳头在……
Okay, okay, okay, we got it Yeah, whip-whipin' but bendin, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, rip, P-O-S! Waring a bear by P-O-S. You can buy it right now on iTunes. His 2012 album We Don't Even Live Here is one of my favorites of all time. You have to get it. We'll have a link on our website. It's 99p i dot org. Radio to P i. From P r x.
好的，好的，好的，我们明白了，是的，驾驶着但转弯，撕裂，撕裂……P-O-S！由P-O-S演唱的《Waring a bear》。你现在可以在iTunes上购买。他2012年的专辑《We Don't Even Live Here》是我有史以来最喜欢的专辑之一。你一定要买。我们的网站上会有链接。网址是99pi.org。Radio to Pi。来自PRX。
Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。